so we will see how the data stacks up if
it turns out that the polling is all
wrong
every one of these pollsters needs to
learn to code like right now
because there are a lot of polls being
done and here is the thing here is the
thing
despite the fact that nationally joe
biden is up very very wide
the fact is that the polls would not
have to be wrong in order for donald
trump to win this election
that's the thing that people are
ignoring when they are getting very
sanguine on the left
about how this election is going to go
i'm looking at the real clear politics
polling average right now
in the real clear politics polling
average in the top battleground states
biden is up on average 2.9 points
and nationally he's up anywhere from six
to ten points by virtually every poll
but in the battleground states biden is
up not all that much
in florida it's within margin of error
in north carolina margin of error in
iowa there's a big poll that came out
over the weekend we'll talk about it in
a second
in which joe biden was down at 41 and
this is a pretty well respected poll
and donald trump was at 48 in minnesota
biden is up only 4.3 percent
in pennsylvania 4.3 percent in arizona
it is margin of error basically dead
even
in nevada biden is up only 3.6 in
michigan
he's up only 5.1 percent in ohio it's
dead even in wisconsin he's up 6.6
percent texas
is also very close and georgia is
basically that even so what does that
mean
it means that there are basically three
election scenarios that are worth
talking about one is
a very very tight trump victory trump
ekes out an electoral college victory he
doesn't win the popular vote there's
pretty much no shot at him winning the
popular vote at this point but it is
possible that he
picks up north carolina he wins florida
he wins arizona and then
he picks up one more state where he
picks up pennsylvania or he picks up
wisconsin right picks up michigan
right most likely those is pennsylvania
and democrats are very nervous about
pennsylvania as we'll talk about in a
second
that is definitely a possibility and the
polls do not have to be wrong
for that possibility to materialize in
fact if there is a surge of trump voters
on election day
there's a lot of focus right now in
early voting focusing on early voting is
almost always a mistake when you see
people
analysts who are looking at the early
voting numbers the reason that's a
mistake is because in 2016 they assumed
that because so many people
were voting for hillary early that meant
that hillary was going to win
that that was just a bunch of new voters
who were voting early it turns out that
early voting might just be cannibalizing
the vote from election day
right you meant to vote on election day
and instead you were like you know what
i'm not wasting my time at the polls
kova's on and so i'm going to go vote uh
a week early
so you didn't vote twice right you voted
once so it's not as though your early
vote mattered more than your late vote
what may be happening here is a bit of a
cannibalization of the later vote by
democrats they're all voting early
meanwhile republicans are waiting until
election day
and you might get a big trump turnout on
election day in fact cnn
rolled out this possibility yesterday
they called this the republican surg
scenario and they trotted out this map
the republican search scenario
is exactly the map that i was talking
about where trump wins north carolina
florida texas arizona
uh and uh he wins ohio and pennsylvania
as well as well as iowa
right this is the most likely trump
victory map the one that we are looking
at right now this is from cbs actually
right this is where trump wins 279
electoral votes and biden wins 259
and it's a very close election even
though biden wins the popular vote
overwhelmingly right this is the best
case scenario i think
for trump the second possible scenario
is that joe biden
wins but he wins narrowly right that
biden flips pennsylvania
right there go back to that map for one
second biden wins pennsylvania and if
biden wins pennsylvania
then that is enough to shift the vote
to joe biden right basically everything
comes down to pennsylvania now the big
problem of course is that pennsylvania
is going to be counting votes for days
after the election so if this thing
comes down to pennsylvania
election night just going it's not going
to end for days on end
the states that report the fastest
florida reports pretty fast north
carolina
starts to report but it takes a while
for north carolina to come in
your first indicator as to how the
night's going to go is probably going to
be florida
so if florida comes in fast and it comes
in for trump then democrats are going to
get
very very nervous if florida comes in
blue the election is all but over at
that point like right off the bat so
florida is going to be
your first indicator as to where things
lie okay so scenario number one is trump
takes out a narrow victory scenario
number two is biden eaks out a narrow
victory scenario number three
is that biden just blows him out right i
mean that's a possibility too biden is
up
in a massive way nationally in a way
that hillary clinton was not hillary
clinton was up
three to five points nationally she
ended up winning by about three points
nationally
in the popular vote of course and then
she ended up losing extremely narrowly
in those blue firewall states and then
pretty broadly in places like iowa
and ohio it is possible that joe biden
bucks the trend here and biden pulls it
out in north carolina
he pulls it out in florida like things
have narrowed in the last week or so
and this is the thing momentum seems to
be with trump at this point
part of that is because you knew there
was going to be an inevitable narrowing
right that usually happens at the very
end of elections
there's a bit of a narrowing so that is
not particularly
unforeseeable but you could end up with
a scenario in which biden wins
everything
right right now if there were no toss-up
states if you look at the the
real clear politics no toss-up map then
what you would see
is biden winning a fairly broad
electoral college victory
he'd win 335 electoral votes if the
election were to hold up to the real
clear politics polling average including
pulling out florida and georgia and
arizona
yeah i'm doubtful that it looks like
that my guess is that if biden wins it's
going to be fairly narrow in the
electoral college and fairly broadly in
the popular vote
so those are your your three scenarios
biden blowout by narrow victory trump
narrow victory right those are the three
scenarios and none of them
are impossible so nate silver over at 5
38 has a piece today titled i'm here to
remind you that trump
can still win right now sort of the
analysts are suggesting that he has
a ten percent shot at winning but he
says a ten percent shot is not a zero
percent shot
and nate silver says the reason that
president trump's chances in our
forecast are about ten percent and not
zero
as in 2016 trump could potentially
benefit from the electoral college
projected margins in the tipping point
states are considerably tighter than the
margins
in the national popular vote more
specifically joe biden's lead in
pennsylvania the most likely tipping
point state is solid but not spectacular
about five points in our polling average
without pennsylvania biden does have
some paths to victory but there's no one
alternative state he can feel especially
secure about
so basically what nate silver is saying
is that if biden were to lose
pennsylvania basically trump wins the
election
well a lot of theories about why trump
can win about those shy trump voters are
probably wrong
systematic polling errors do occur it's
hard to predict them ahead of time or to
anticipate the reasons
in advance there is some chance says
nate sober that trump could win
illegitimately
to a large extent these scenarios are
beyond the scope of our forecast we'll
get to that in a second
because for all the talk about how trump
supporters are readying for violence and
all this
there's really only one group in the
country that's readying for violence and
the media
are fostering it the media are fostering
a notion that voter suppression
is taking over the country the
republicans are trying to throw out
legally
cast ballots and that is just really not
true there's not evidence of widespread
voter suppression we're going to have
record voting
this year voter turnout in georgia in
texas
in florida is at all-time highs it is
not close
there's some chance of a recount
according to 538 about four percent or
an electoral college tie
around 0.5 percent and
nate silver concludes before we proceed
further short philosophical mode
i hate when people use his phrases such
as nate silver is giving biden a 90
chance we aren't giving anybody anything
instead we're mapping uncertainty in
other words if biden leads by about nine
points nationally and eight points in
wisconsin and five points in
pennsylvania and two points in florida
how does that translate into the
probability of victory people have a
tendency
to go from ninety percent shot means
that there's a ten percent shot trump
wins two ninety percent shot means
there's 100 chance
that biden wins and that obviously is
untrue right now
the bottom line is that if biden were to
win by two to three points in the
national popular vote then there is a
a better than average chance a 57 shot
that trump actually wins the electoral
college biden needs to win
by somewhere between three and five
points in order for him to win the
national election so we'll see
how all of that turns out high voter
turnout the the kind of typical
conventional wisdom suggests that's bad
for republicans the evidence there is
pretty mix as poster kirsten sultan
sanderson
has said before i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the ben shapiro show if you
did go ahead and hit the subscribe
button so you stay up to date on all of
our future content